hey youtubers is Charlie so we learned a
whole bunch of stuff about thor ragnarok
it's basically planet hulk and we
learned a little bit about when the next
teaser is coming so here we go there's a
new round of the spider-man giveaway
going on now - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything so much to talk about
they've revealed so much about the movie
but we don't even have a trailer yet so
I'll try to address all this stuff
number 10 they're totally doing Planet
Hulk with a few minor changes now there
I mean there's no way they're going to
do the exact comic book storyline that
would be an entire movie by itself in
fact they turned it into an animated
movie so if you haven't seen that you
can check that out I mean really it's
like the cliffnotes for the comic book
so I just recommend reading the planet
whole comic book it's crazy it has great
artwork you get to see full-blown
gladiator Hulk just completely smash a
world which isn't to be confused with
world breaker Hulk when he comes back
from Planet Hulk so there are a whole
bunch of questions about Hulk's presence
in the film in whether or not they're
gonna do Sekar like what is this planet
that they're fighting on that's on the
other end of the universe from Asgard
number 9 if Thor is forced to fight Hulk
in the arena that was actually part of
the comic-con teaser day they showed off
he was just then bull rushing each other
inside the arena how did Hulk get into
outer space in the first place we
haven't seen him since the very end of
age of Ultron we know what happened to
Thor at the end of age of Ultron he
returned to Asgard to seek more clarity
on what was going on with his visions
like he saw visions of the Infinity
stones we got that funny teaser from
Comic Con where he's living with Darrell
that's not actually what was happening
that was just like a funny mock-up for
the DVD of civil war what actually
happened is is he went back to Asgard
and has been a little over a year you
have to remember that the things move in
real time in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
so if civil war was like last spring
then age of Ultron was a year before
that so Thor went back to Asgard so
there's been this big stretch of time
where he's been banished to this
gladiatorial planet whether or not it's
the car just remains to be seen but
presumably during that time Loki hatched
his plan to take care of Asgard to bring
hella from her realm from hell and just
based on the pitch like we know that
Loki comes to earth to find Odin meaning
he probably recants and like bites off a
little more than he can chew he probably
doesn't want to bring about Ragnarok he
just wants to be king that's all he
wants hella is the one that wants to
destroy Asgard so that's probably the
turning point for Loki where he's like
okay this isn't what I signed on for so
he helps Thor out but that's much later
in the film so in the time after age of
Ultron but before we see Thor fighting
in the arena there's probably some fight
with Loki Loki probably finds a way to
banish him to this planet far away from
Asgard so that he can't cause him any
trouble
number eight Hulk in space how did it
happen so at the end of age of Ultron
sort of like the Planet Hulk comic book
he jettisons into outer space in the
Quinjet that's probably what happens in
just crash lands on whatever planet it
is he's forced to fight in the arena so
I'm just expecting them to be as simple
as possible with that like he flew in
outer space because he felt like he
couldn't be around other people he just
crashed landed on this planet but number
7 if they are doing Sekar what does that
say about the comic book stuff because
you have the Red King the old power what
about his son scar so I'm not expecting
them to do the Hulk's son there'll be a
lot of Hulk in the movie but Marvel
doesn't seem to have any plans to do a
Hulk movie so they would probably save
stuff like that if they were gonna do a
solo Hulk film so like I said because
it's been a long time since the age of
Ultron hook has probably been in outer
space on this planet for a long time
just like the Planet Hulk comic book
he's probably forged some relationships
in the arena so they'll probably be some
nods to that but I'm only expecting them
to spend you know maybe like thirty
percent of this movie in that gladiator
area it'll be like one of the big action
set pieces of the film then it'll turn
into a buddy roadtrip comedy
they'll come back to Asgard smash
everyone go find Odin smash everyone
again you'll have your big climax like
the big final battle of the film so
there'll be a lot of arena but they're
not going to spend the entire film
fighting in the arena so just look in
the background of shots for Easter eggs
from Planet Hulk like a lot of times
what Marvel will do like when they do
big crowd shots is they'll just work
people anything if they don't have
speaking parts so you'll probably see a
lot of the characters from the Planet
Hulk comic book but it'll just be it
like Easter Egg level so number six the
whole cast limitless potential for
strength how is it possible
to contain him in an arena but this is
also probably something they're gonna
borrow from the planet whole comic book
he has like a control collar it's like a
little device they attached to him that
just suppresses his powers the only ways
for him to get it off is to one either
become so angry that the Hulk Hulk's out
they actually did that during x-men
access this is what it looks like when
the Hulk Hulk's out like if you thought
he looked crazy during Avengers age of
Ultron when he was over the edge this is
way worse than that so you can do that
or you can just find a way to remove it
by force just like having it smashed and
whatever fight that they have so maybe
when he bites Thor is when they get that
control collar op but I'm also guessing
that the Grandmaster the character that
Jeff Goldblum is playing has something
to do with this because if you have an
elder of the universe someone with that
much power he could probably find a way
to contain the Hulk at least for a
little while but number five what is the
Grandmaster doing in all this so if the
collector just wants to collect things
like he wants the infinity gems he
probably has his own plan for them the
way they described the Grandmaster is
that he's sort of like an intergalactic
pleasure seeker like he's ancient so
he's just looking for a really
interesting game he's looking for a good
time
so Loki probably contacts him and teases
him with the idea of Hulk fighting Thor
and is like oh hey why don't we set this
up so that's probably how the
Grandmaster gets involved but number
four big thing here Thor does not have
his hammer so it also sounds like
they're doing some of the unworthy Thor
from the comics if you haven't been
reading the comics the main version of
Thor
became unworthy so he wasn't able to
wield the hammer anymore what happened
recently though is that he found out
about another hammer from a different
universe that he could wield so he's
going after that is actually the hammer
that belonged to the Thor from The
Ultimates universe from before secret
wars so if you if you didn't read secret
wars you don't know what's going on
don't worry about it they're not doing
that there's only one version of Thor in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe there's
only one hammer so don't worry about it
it's just that the unworthy Thor is a
story about a Thor that is separated
from his hammer so the hammer is still
at Asgard Thor is on the other side of
the universe on this gladiator planet so
if he doesn't get the hammer back before
he finds Odin then Loki would be the
only way for him to get around
have access to the Hulk's Quinn jet so
there will be a period of time when Thor
is travelling around the universe
without his hammer like doing it slow
style the hammer itself can open portals
like he can travel faster than life it's
a little bit trickier than that that's
why they've kind of avoided that in the
movies so far like thus far in the
movies he's only used the Rainbow Bridge
to travel so number three that Doctor
Strange post-credits scene now we know
that a little bit more about what's
happening with the plot of Thor Ragnarok
when does that Thor scene in Doctor
Strange happen because it sounds like
he's working with Loki at that point
like Loki's either helped him find
Doctor Strange or helped bring them to
earth somehow so that might fall like
really late in the Thor movie after he's
made it off the gladiator planet but the
big thing here is that Odin has to be
present returned to full power with the
odinforce before the big climax of the
movie the big final battle that will be
Ragnarok we know a little bit about that
hella unleashes all the monsters of
Ragnarok things are blowing apart at the
seams
Odin has to step in with the odinforce
to take them all down and banish them
back to their individual realms
so not expecting Odin to come back to
like the very very end of the film but
number two another big character that
they don't mention the synopsis Thanos
in the infinity gems so James Gunn has
been very clear that there is absolutely
no Thanos inside his movie he did not
say no Thanos in a post-credits scene so
they could do that because he also said
they're not going to do infinity gems
during guardians to and you just like
there's so much stuff that you have to
do with the infinity gems leading into
infinity war that they at least have to
touch on it briefly during Thor Ragnarok
so it makes sense that the two
space-based Marvel movies have some
connective tissue between them because
guardians is coming in the spring Thor
is coming in November but as for actual
Thanos during Thor Ragnarok we don't
know a lot about that like you know
maybe a little bit of him at the very
end of the movie just trying to use all
the chaos to step in
join the tesseract and then move on to
the next gem I know a lot of people have
theories about the soul gem maybe it's
inside Heimdall maybe it'll have
something to do with Captain Marvel's
powers they could always leave one gem
for the very beginning of Avengers
infinity wars so if they're going to do
that it'll probably be the sole gem
but number one big thing is when is the
actual freaking trailer going to come
everyone wants to know where's the
footage we've seen a whole bunch of
behind the scenes stuff if you were a
Comic Con you saw some production art
there was concept art of Hulk getting
ready to punch Firelord Serdar
there was Fenris wolf it was a Loki in
the Grand Master watching Thor in the
Hulk bulrush each other inside the arena
that was really all they showed off at
Comic Con so a lot of that will probably
make it into the final trailer just
looking a lot more polished with special
effects but think about it this way
there are two big Marvel movies coming
up one at the beginning of May guardians
of the galaxy 2 which is about six
months before Thor Ragnarok comes out
and then you have spider-man during the
summer so what will happen is is they'll
probably drop the teaser trailer at
least with guardians of the galaxy to
hitting theaters and then again when
spider-man hits theaters so up until
that point up until like May when
guardians drops most of their time is
going to be spent promoting guardians of
the galaxy in spider-man so even though
like spider-man's a Sony movie and
they're the ones posting most of the
trailers Marvel's kind of cross posting
so the earliest I'm expecting to see a
Thor trailer is sometime around the end
of April beginning of May they could
always drop some more concept art or
like a really small teaser before them
to supposedly a Doctor Strange DVD bonus
feature called team Thor part two team
Thor was that funny comic-con trailer
that they released with Thor with
Darrell so that will probably be a
follow up that will help push into the
beginning of Thor Ragnarok so if you
ever wanted a reason to buy a DVD this
would be it so it'll be like the closest
thing to get to a teaser before the
actual teaser comes out but let me know
what are you guys most hype about I know
everybody can't wait to see gladiator
Hulk Planet Hulk stuff it's going to be
awesome so what's going to happen next
is because I pushed an arrow video for
this like I dropped all this information
that'll be the next video to post so
arrow Prometheus coming tomorrow morning
will you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for a new flash trailer
and you can click here for new
spider-man homecoming thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight